Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina
genes.
Are you ready to,
uh,
do some dates?
Oh yeah.
You realize we're going to do this show,
right?
Is that what we're doing?
Yeah,
we were just adding fiber.
Hello.
Bye.
Sounds made the beat.
We played his stuff before.
It's good.
That's good.
I'm in crawling me North Carolina this weekend,
just Friday and Saturday.
That's a good name for it.
Crawling me.
Crawl in me.
Also known as Raleigh.
Um,
following weekend.
Loosen her Ville.
Uh,
Kentucky
let loose and her yet.
Yeah.
Uh,
so if you're in the,
in the bill,
some people from there call it that,
but I like Louisville.
It's nice.
I do too.
That's top dogs hometown.
That's right.
So a global global from Louisville Buddy.
I'm drawing big kits on you.
Yeah,
thanks Beck.
Oh Wow.
That was a huge,
he got it.
Um,
so crawling me loose Harville and then fill her up.
Delphia it's finally coming up for big shows at the Trocadero theatre and fill
her up.
Delphia uh,
there's only one show that has tickets left,
so if you,
if you want it,
don't wait.
They will not be there by the time that rolls around.
The third week in November,
I'm drawing tiny little teddies on me.
Like pert what doesn't make sense?
You got big old big old cans.
I do west her balls,
beach,
Florida,
the Improv.
First Week in December,
get one.
Um,
and the New Year's Eve in Orlando.
I'll tell you this year's Eve,
New Year's eve and mom,
Lando,
after the new year,
I go on a crazy tour.
I'm not going to list all the dates,
but they're at Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com I will tell you just that we've added
a show in Minneapolis and we're adding a show in Boston at the Wilbur tickets
for that second show.
Go on sale Friday,
this Friday jeans.
What do you got?
Not as much as you,
I'm going to close out my year.
I'm doing the DC Improv December 9th and 10th,
like quick a quick one out and then back and I'm working on another string of
one nighters for 2017 it's being worked on so I can announce anything yet.
But yeah,
I had so much fun doing the main mother,
God,
his tour that I think it's,
I think I got to go back and you're building is going to be very cool though.
It's so fun.
Yeah.
I love doing this model Brown.
All right,
love your gold chain.
Maria.
Have a jam master.
Jay,
you're wearing the Adidas.
I got the Dukie rope on.
Is that what I call it Duke?
Yeah,
it is Harrison.
rub down.
Yeah,
rest in peace.
Jam Master Jay.
No,
I love them.
I feel like,
you know,
I inspired him in so many ways to be a great DJ.
He did say that before he passed.
I remember that.
And he's like,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm saying no cold cold crush crew,
you know,
saying you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
You know,
I'm like,
you know,
let's get into this.
You're ready to go.
I feel like we haven't done this shown weeks.
Why does it feel like that?
I think cause we did two.
We did,
didn't we do too one day or something?
We did.
We got ahead of ourselves of our travels.
Right.
So the has been like,
it's been a while and it's son,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
Do it
fabulous.
Good on this committee and peers.
I love this so much.
We're going to get into it in a second here.
It's just so great.
Oh my God.
Love him to this
role.
Go to your mom's house.
Christina
here.
Okay.
Can I be sincere for a moment?
So these past three weeks of shows have just been outrageously fun for me.
Great.
I mean,
I just want to say thanks to the people have come out Charlotte fans,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Charlotte man,
friend,
disco and Jude or Teddy's.
Yeah,
Keller.
Then just killer fund for me,
man,
really fast.
We have the best fans that run that.
I just did have one nighters.
Yeah,
it was like bananas fun.
Everybody I met after the shows was a huge,
your mom's house.
You're right about that.
And not only are we just saying that you don't understand how often,
like on these all the time,
but even these last three weeks where that shows have been packed and that the
staff and management goes,
you bring out the best that they say that to me too.
Yeah.
Your fans are the best test.
They're like,
they know they're polite.
They're intelligent.
Yeah.
They're ranking,
their tipping people are civilized people.
They just can't believe it.
So I just want to say,
because,
um,
it is really fun to be able to go out,
do your shows that you know,
that you,
that you do,
but have just great crowds supporting you.
So yeah.
Thanks everybody.
Some updates on indie and sensee,
but I,
after we get into this first all,
we can do this for a,
we'll get into this then a little bit.
Okay.
Um,
do you know what I love?
Is it fif just had a kissy attack?
Yeah.
Like sometimes he just goes,
okay.
Me.
Yeah.
And then he demands and I pick him up and now he's resting his,
his chin on my arm.
He's such a sweet boy.
I want to clone him too.
Before I know you guys right now,
25 grand,
is that all to clone your favorite dog?
Kind of worth it when you think about it,
I think when you,
but the thing is their personality won't be the same.
Are you sure that's what they said?
Well,
I mean how could it be if it's a clown?
Because he doesn't have the same experiences though it doesn't have the same
trauma.
Right?
It's like people.
So what we could do is get the clone.
Yeah.
And then just send them like give them to a real bad family for it.
Send him to a kill shot.
We'll pay them more to,
he'll be like,
we'll give you another 25 grand you,
she'd be shitty for a few years and then we'll get him.
So then will be 50,000 in and then like we'll get him like all skid it back.
Right guys,
they'll beef experience again if the fever,
the total fee of experience and he has to get sick with like for viruses.
The minute we get at,
I don't even remind,
remember how they lied to us that the kill shelter and they go,
he just has the Doggie hooping cough,
wherever the fuck that's called.
And we took him home and he had about four viruses.
It was terrible,
terrible,
terrible dog on what?
We took the dog to the pet hospital and they,
they had a sign a do not resuscitate,
Redo it.
No,
but listen to it.
But the bright,
the bride,
you know,
thing at the end of the tunnel is that he's the best dog and he's happy and
healthy and none of that mattered because he's the best now to Nieto.
No,
no,
no.
You don't want to go there and not yet.
Not yet.
Okay.
Past weekend judo titties,
I was with full charge,
love,
full charge.
Uh,
so Thursday we do our third.
Is He still doing his podcast?
The full charge power hour as far.
Well,
you know,
it's funny you ask because he is on the
road right now I'm doing a bunch of road gigs,
so you should check them out online,
follow them on Twitter or whatever.
If you haven't,
I know he's got a bunch of gigs coming up.
Like what you're doing Raleigh together this week and you call it Raleigh crawl
on me.
Yeah.
So,
but we did our Thursday show and afterwards we had dinner with Eric Schaefer.
Um,
that was airy areas.
Great.
How's his butt hole?
I think it's fine.
He's shooting a special and a couple of weeks again.
Geez,
I'm really ambitious idea to what's the idea?
It's a like a almost like a half and half.
Like he was like 40 minutes on one subject and he drops a sheet or something,
changes shirts and was 40 minutes on another subject.
Cool.
Yeah,
that'll be interesting.
That's what I'm saying.
It's an ambitious idea.
Where is it going to go?
Do we know?
I Dunno.
I think it's going to comedy central.
I mean he's part of the network,
you know,
cause he has this thing there so it's always going to be there I think.
But yeah,
I'm really happy for,
he's going to be in Austin.
I don't know if there's still tickets available,
but if you,
if you can get them,
he'll be at cap city doing the special.
Um,
so I did a podcast with him too,
but on Thursday we just,
we did Matt and I did the show.
We go meet airy Schaefer for dinner.
We have dinner,
then he's got,
uh,
a spot at the cellar.
So Matt and I were like,
well,
go ahead.
You know,
we're,
we're just,
we're having new whatever,
post dinner drink or something,
you know.
So,
and he texts me,
he goes,
come over [inaudible] we're,
we're,
you're not far from us,
so just walk over.
It's a nice walk.
So we're like,
all right,
we'll walk over.
So we're walking down bleaker street,
heading towards,
uh,
the seller and the most amazing,
wonderful thing happens that door to a bar opens and a fight.
Two guys spill out on the street.
Something so exciting about fights,
you know,
and you know,
I don't like,
I don't want to see brutal violence.
Like,
I don't want to see someone's head kicked open and see them have a seizure.
But just a fight.
A battle,
like a bar drunk fight.
Yeah.
We're like,
you know,
a good shot,
a good punch.
I,
you know,
like I said,
I don't want to see devastation,
but a fight is exciting because it's something primal about special.
Yeah.
And it makes you feel alive.
It does.
You get a little adrenaline rush fighting myself.
Right.
But I like other people.
Well it's like,
you know,
uh,
any fight,
like,
you know,
if you,
if you drive by and there's a fight,
you,
you stop.
If there's a fight somewhere like down the street in Beverly Hills and there was
us right in the middle,
the middle of the rough day or something,
they're like,
wait,
who's fighting?
I met a member as we crossed the light lights behind us were like,
they don't do that.
Most neighborhoods where like there was a fight for 30 seconds and then police
were there in Beverly Hills.
It's kind of like that,
you know,
whole con thing that people talk about.
Well,
you know,
how about why don't you respond like this in bad neighborhoods?
And it's like,
well in Rampart we also heard a lot of fighting and never showed up.
I was fine.
They can have,
they shown their helicopter lights in her own right,
but not,
yeah,
he never actually showed up physically.
Anyways,
these two guys are fighting and you know,
it's,
it's sloppy fighting.
It's sloppy
guys.
You got to do the demographics.
Yeah,
I mean I think uh,
I would say one guy was like 25 thin,
um,
you know,
clean cut,
real,
real slender build.
The other guy was huskier bigger,
stronger build and it seemed like the Husky,
your guy was really actually composed and clearly the other guy was drunk and it
seemed to be the type of thing.
Have you gotta get Outta here for whatever you just did in there?
The skinny guy did something.
Yeah,
the skinny guy did something bad.
Cause usually guys,
you guys are very primal and we put together that the skinny guy name was Ivan,
but men are very primal.
Like you've told me that you'll walk into a room and even unconsciously size up
guys.
Guys do it all the time.
But women don't,
we don't walk into a room and we do it on beauty in social settings.
Yes.
And social settings.
Women figure out where they are and the beauty scale and men figure out where
they are on the physical strength is the strongest in here.
Even without going into it like,
hey,
it's unconscious.
You just gauge it.
Yeah.
So it seemed like Ivan was being like,
dude,
and he was being really hard re restrained and he was fighting back really hard,
not like really throwing punches,
but it was a lot of shoving.
He tore part of the other guy's shirt and it was,
it was very aggressive.
It's fun.
So as that happened,
three or four other guys come out.
One is an old guy who's probably,
I would say when I say old,
I mean well over 60.
Okay.
A white hair and you know,
he's formally dressed.
Um,
and then two other guys,
including the one black guy.
And as we're walking,
I,
I think I'm on the phone with you,
right?
Yeah,
I heard it from here.
Yeah.
Uh,
so,
or are,
or you called as was half forget.
So yeah,
you do call it a moment after.
I just want to say hi.
So you hadn't talked,
you hadn't called just yet.
So as we're walking though,
um,
Matt goes,
Hey,
do you know who that black eyes?
And I go,
who keep in mind we're 20 to 35 feet away.
I go,
he goes,
Oh hey,
that's this Cuba Gooding Jr.
And I go,
yeah,
like I,
I giggle like I heard you say that and then I too went,
okay.
Right.
Anyway,
so what else did you guys do tonight?
Yeah,
yeah,
but I'm saying you heard it after.
This is not at the time.
So at the time you have,
I haven't,
I'm not talking to you yet.
So I go,
yeah.
And I thought he was just making like,
you know,
like if there's an Asian guy and you go,
hey,
that's Mister Miyagi.
Okay.
Like I thought you just making like a bad racial joke,
like just a throwaway.
And then he turns around and it's Cuba Gooding jr and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And he is really in the mix of this thing,
splitting this up.
Dude.
Ivan went in and out multiple times.
They finally dragged him halfway down the street.
I see the old guy as he's trying to restrain him,
hit the pavement,
which is terrible.
Nothing like seeing an old person fall.
It's just terrible.
And then I see Cuba
Cuba's,
yeah,
it's such a weird name.
Cuba.
Cuba comes back and he goes,
I'll tell you,
he's not a boxer.
He goes,
can't keep that Chin down man.
And then he goes back inside,
comes out like three times.
Then you call like as the second time he's walked out and I go,
we just saw Cuba Gooding jr break up a fight.
And we're like,
okay.
The same way I did.
And then I had to give the phone to Matt,
so I was like,
I'm serious.
And then you talked to Matt and he was like,
no,
it's really true.
Can we go to junior's breaking up fights on the streets of the Lower East
village here?
Crazy.
Yeah.
It's really,
really weird because so New York that,
you know what I mean,
that you like walking down the street actually more la like to have a huge
celebrity be in a weird place like that.
I Dunno.
I feel like that's a very New York thing too.
The fighting is definitely New York cause I heard it in the background but
celebrities are all over in New York.
They just walk around over there too.
I had my first Paparazzi experience.
You did take a picture of your no,
the video guys like the TMZ.
Yeah.
But it happened.
It happened in the best possible way.
It happened without a doubt.
Well with them not wanting to get me,
what happened was this,
I get out of a car,
like a car service car and as I'm,
the driver gives me my bags,
I'm walking to my hotel,
a guy in a car opens the door like a parked car and he goes,
Tom Secura and I go,
what's up man?
He goes,
dude,
I love your stuff.
And I go,
thanks man.
And then the pop rock to pop rocks.
You guys looked at each other and I go,
what's up man?
You guys are here for me.
Right?
And they're like,
yeah.
And I go,
nobody more famous.
It's coming up.
That was it.
[inaudible] interview with TMZ.
I mean I just walked into the hotel.
It wasn't going to stay there and talk to guys that I knew are not there to,
to video,
but they were waiting.
There were some musician or something at the hotel.
Wow.
I think it was like a pop star.
So they,
they were all camped out.
Oh Wow.
Well it sounds like you had a star studded east coast adventure.
I know I saw a celebrity to in Indianapolis in Indianapolis,
Indiana.
Apple tits where,
who?
Famous to our show a little Yoshi.
Oh,
he is very famous.
Yoshi Obayashi is very famous and your mom's house circles and he was in
Indianapolis of all weird things and he did a guest set on my show jerking off
while licking my,
having a girl,
like my boss from my angle,
while she's licking my balls,
I'm punching her fucking stupid face.
Yeah,
that's Yoshi.
And we went for lunch after the next day with like two normal friends of his,
like a married couple.
Weird.
Right.
It's super weird and I just think the Jews are great.
And um,
it was just weird to see Yoshi having functionally like good relationships with
these people and they were the nicest and we had a lovely meal and he's doing
stand up and just traveling around a lot.
And he says that,
uh,
your mom's house fans give him the most love of all the podcasts that he's done
when he,
when,
when he came up on my show bananas,
they went bananas for his Legendary Status Ledge if he did it.
Now when we move and we are equipped for guests.
Really?
Yeah.
We got to have him on again.
Yeah,
I told him we would once the studio is a new one,
so this is too small in Africa.
Sucks.
Um,
but yeah,
so he's doing great and it was such a trip to see him.
And I went back to Cincinnati and I tried building another fart.
I went to skyline Chili,
I aid at Applebee's.
But I don't think anything can compare to that fateful day.
Once in a lifetime recreate now it's like a double pipe.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So you know,
we both had celebrity sightings.
Both are famous Quba big deal.
Okay.
Yeah.
Original name.
So Cuba,
how old is Cuba now?
I Dunno,
I got,
he's got,
he's all 50 now.
Late forties.
He's a old,
what am I going to say?
Head?
I in trouble every time.
You know what I'm going to say?
No,
I don't know.
There's an old joke.
Oh,
it's an old joke.
Um,
all right.
So how can we get on to plant?
Um,
first of all,
may I preface this by saying that you've done many things in Showbiz.
You've done a late night spots.
You've done Conan.
Yeah.
What else would be done in late,
late,
late night genre,
the late,
late,
late show with currency.
Um,
you've actually,
you've done counting as a standup and then you came back and you sat on the
couch,
you did panel and both times or how many times you've done this stuff,
you've just been like,
oh yeah,
I'm doing Conan tonight.
No biggie.
When I announced you that I was pregnant,
you were like,
that's neat.
No,
no biggie.
Um,
you going on this show,
you were ear to ear.
Look,
look at you now.
This is,
this is like you watching Henry Portrait of a serial killer happened.
You were so stoked to go on this show and you were so thrilled the day of and so
thrilled days after.
I've never seen you this happy.
You don't.
The only bummer is I tell you this now,
they cut out so much stuff.
Um,
he told me,
he's like,
oh,
there's no rules to whatever they are in the cuts that I've seen.
I've got bleeped and they cut out like half.
I know bad words more than anything.
Like most people who learn a second language and so it was cursing a lot in
Spanish.
Do they just straight up cutouts?
Maybe they didn't think you were as much of a dirt bag as you are.
I think that's the thing.
He's like normal people have no boundaries.
Yeah.
Like he was saying things like,
it's like they go,
how were you at sports?
And he goes,
oh I had like two left feet,
you know.
And they laughed.
And then I was like I said in Spanish,
I said fuck,
I was the fucking best.
And then cut out the weeds.
Yeah.
They go beep and then they cut the rest of it.
Um,
we were afraid of our Guatemalan nanny's mom saying,
yeah,
I know cause she loves planting Ito and we were worried that she's going to
quit.
You do English and Spanish by the way,
on the show.
What happens is normally if you're like me,
they want you to speak English the whole time because the game kind of for them
is that there's an English speaker on and then kind of make fun of you and
stuff.
Well they,
they,
people wear ear pieces and they translate and it makes it like a clash of
cultures.
Right.
So I do speak English and spent,
but I'll,
you'll see
he's a Spanish actor from Mexico.
Oh,
okay.
[inaudible]
beeps already right out of the gate.
I said,
no ma'am,
it's way,
which is like,
you gotta be like,
like don't fuck with me.
Like say it again.
You gotta be kidding me.
No Mommy,
no mommy.
And then I said,
well Diane,
say Linda and they excellent.
So they blink my mess and then they bleed.
But why put the excellent and it does like Buddha is like a,
they say it.
Yeah,
it's horror.
But in,
in Peru it's said as a word of like emphasis,
like kind of old glory.
But it's like if he's like you said,
how good were you at sports in high school?
And I went,
Fuck.
Awesome.
Okay.
It was like that.
So I'm saying like,
fuck excellent.
So great that I cleaned it.
[inaudible]
he's like looking over at his producer,
like,
look at this guy.
This guy's the best.
Yeah,
this guy is ear to ear smiles the whole time.
He's all energy cause that's Latin,
uh,
show pop up.
Big expression.
Sabido he got,
there's a picture on my Instagram of when I'm on this and they're there,
I'll show you what they're doing.
But him in the background,
it's somebody wrote like,
I've never been that happy as that guy is this guy because he gets,
yeah,
he's just a very big,
big show emotion.
How much do you love your mother if you eat something of hers?
And she goes,
how is it?
And you go,
it's good.
It's good.
Yeah,
you don't love it.
I go,
yeah,
no,
I love it.
But do you love it?
Love it.
She gets mad at me cause I don't know.
He wants to know if your Lord,
I love you.
Love you.
Here's the next club.
Okay.
When I was at,
when I was a kid,
I'll tell you this part,
in English,
when I was a kid,
I would go spend my summers in Lima,
right?
So I would go to class and the teacher would see me without papers,
without books,
without pen,
because I was just visiting.
So one day in class,
he goes a know,
like really mad,
right?
Whoa.
Why don't you have your books?
Oh,
he brings me to the front of the class.
He makes me face the class and he tells them,
ask this kid why he doesn't have his books.
So I say it's because I'm from getting gold land.
Yeah.
And I don't have my book.
And he said,
now you can ask him whatever you want.
So this kid goes to make fun of me to bully me.
He goes,
uh,
[inaudible] basis.
How many times did I do man?
I said the penis.
He [inaudible]
right.
You're madre.
Cause I gotta say so basically the kid,
this is a true story.
They put me in front of the class.
It was like really shocking.
You know,
I never heard this story.
Yeah.
So it was like the one of the,
my first summer going to class and I would basically,
I was in an all boys Catholic school.
You wore,
I wore the uniform and everything,
but I didn't,
I was a visitor and they just stuck me in classes and they're just like,
just sit in the back.
Right.
So I didn't have papers and stuff on my desk.
And most of the time nobody noticed.
But one time a teacher looked at my desk and was like,
what are you doing?
Like you don't have like who are you?
But at the end like,
you know,
they address you like that it's more old school,
you know?
And
you mean they don't worry about your pronouns or if you're on a Vegan gluten
die,
microaggressions,
they go for extra aggression over aggression.
Yeah,
front of the class.
Imagine that and being a foreigner,
oh,
it's terrifying.
Like heart racing.
And then I started to tell him that someone jumped in and they're like,
he's,
he's American student.
He's not even enrolled here.
And there.
He was like,
oh.
And he's like,
well,
ask away,
kids,
ask,
ask him whatever you want.
And the first kid goes,
how many times did they do you masturbate?
And then teacher didn't correct nothing.
I think he was a,
Pete wanted to see like what you're made of good.
I love,
but I answered the kid,
I said,
it depends if I think of your mother like six or seven times.
And then I said,
uh,
me,
Mason,
Mondo [inaudible],
which means,
uh,
they,
they call me a dead hand cause I'm a jerk off so much.
Got It.
Yeah.
And uh,
anyways,
it killed in the class and then there was a little bit of fucking around and
then went back to my seat.
See.
But I do like that old school academia stuff,
like they're not respecting your pronouns are not worried at all.
No.
Shame.
Shame is a wonderful,
powerful tool.
And it kind of didn't it make you a tougher,
more resilient human of course honed your comedy skills.
Need fear,
fear,
shame.
Yeah.
All wonderful motivator.
Anxiety.
Yeah,
but it all motivate me.
They cut out the thing,
you know,
they cut out.
Well I'll beep now,
but they don't send tile.
It's not like Pooka con nothing.
That'd be great if they still wrote it out.
I know,
I know.
I love the,
every week
he goes,
I'll leave on us as he can with
[inaudible].
So here's the game.
They bring out this chick,
she has objects inside her tight gold.
So in this tight gold zip up suit,
like just things like a coffee mug on a phone.
And the whole idea is you're supposed to touch her right with your,
a blindfold.
And also,
um,
they have headphones and music playing on you and secret touching games.
You could touch and games and you touch her and then you go.
But it's supposed to be enticing because you're touching a right,
a beautiful girl,
but is,
you're just,
you know what I love about Latin TV?
It's so pervy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I don't understand what's going on,
but sometimes I just watch the Latin channel.
Yeah.
And it's all lecherous.
It's like Benny Benny Hill show.
The best part too is that for the setup,
but you don't see here,
they bring us out and they're like,
they're like,
hey,
like when you see her,
go ahead and react.
So that's your big reaction there.
Yeah.
This is Tom's big reaction
and at,
yeah.
Wow.
No,
but I did it.
I did it Super Latin where I walked over and I went like,
whoa.
Like I like a big gesture and I was like,
oh,
la.
And I'm supposed to,
you're supposed to like just really Ogle or you know,
so they're like,
all right fellas.
And then they tell us like,
you're going to get to touch her everywhere.
Yeah.
It's super pervy this is sexual harassment.
I totally,
um,
yeah,
this is very,
uh,
UN-PC.
Yeah.
So here's the
he
eagles.
I live on us.
I think [inaudible] it doesn't mean
that you'll get through it.
They bring out,
they bring out a guy.
This is a
melon.
That's a good bit.
It's a good bit.
That's a good,
really funny.
That's really funny.
Yeah.
What a fun show.
It is fun.
Um,
and they also,
when they do,
let me show you this.
I liked your reaction.
You did the,
you really sold the,
sold that,
right.
Did the blow the fuck guys,
did you say [inaudible] I was like,
guys,
I'm not gay.
I did that.
You know,
did you go k [inaudible] we learned that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Believe me again.
I got my seat there.
One of my answers.
Not only do they bleep completely.
Yeah,
that's the count here.
Yes.
Okay.
Can you tell something about my board that looks different?
Zero.
No,
he's holding the board and the guy next to me,
oh,
what's all bleeped out?
They blurt out my answers too because that's how vulgar I was.
Hilarious.
One of them,
they blurt out a word,
one of them,
they blurt out completely my answer.
Look,
what did you say?
Dildos?
No,
I said okay.
So the first one was um,
because I knew it was a dude.
Okay.
So I go,
I was touching and I go,
ah glassworks they linty which is like a great ass.
And he said like in the room like,
cause you don't,
you wear headphones.
He was like,
dude,
that killed.
But oh cause you can't even hear yourself talking to hear anything.
Then how do you know when he's like,
what do you feel?
Cause they just tell you to keep guessing.
So before you go,
yeah,
you're just like,
ah,
yeah.
So I was like [inaudible] and then I wait.
Or You could hear laugh,
like kind of through the,
over the music you move on.
So they believed that at or,
or they they,
they didn't even put it on answers.
Well she told you to go for it and then TV.
Go for it maybe.
I guess so.
I guess I was way too vulgar.
Why Volcker?
And then they,
they blurt out at test too.
He can
like titties.
I said he's got small titties this fine.
You can tell.
I tell him it was a dude anyways.
Right.
If they didn't hit you to it,
the joke beforehand kind of thing.
You could tell it's a brow.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Oh fuck.
I should have grabbed that coffee mug.
Have been like a huge cock.
You know,
like in his pants they blurt out your answers.
[inaudible]
I will say planting Nieto has got a good look for a clown.
He's been doing it 40 years.
It looks really cool.
Actually.
My kids,
the coloring he chooses,
I like the purple.
I liked
the glitter guide.
Stock your game.
[inaudible] I [inaudible]
I don't understand this.
I don't think people,
okay,
so what they do is we're sitting at a table,
three of us Lolo the actor,
the host splint that Nieto in me,
and there's a Domino's on the table.
Huge ones,
uh,
with the,
the digits,
the numbers face down and they spin the table around and then you turn over,
you randomly pick and you flip it over at all at the same time.
So loaded Lolo has the highest then and in me I have the lowest.
That means I lose.
Okay,
so this is,
yeah.
Okay.
It's just a silly like go fish and the loser.
They pour a mug of beer down your pants.
Fun.
So right now I just found out that I lost,
not a clown is going to put it down.
You're
in love the shit man.
Did you feel it on your course?
This is like you peed your pants there.
Yeah.
Does it,
does your Dick and balls hurt when something cold?
Is it?
Do you get brain freeze on your Dick and balls?
Cole just,
I dunno.
I mean we're talking about freezing cold,
everything.
Just kind of,
you know,
with that,
everything just shrinks more.
It really does.
You just,
you just get tight and you shrink now.
Yeah.
I love how the shame,
shame you.
And then they showed the floor Leggy au Lait.
You mean PB everywhere?
No,
they're showing that the beer man through my pants.
BP.
I got one more thing in here.
They've already lost.
I just don't,
I got it.
Yup.
So that's another dirty joke.
I said I already have my,
my thing.
So Little Pie Rito.
Yeah.
So I don't know what we're going to put this.
Hello
on.
I'm the assistant.
So wait,
they're funneling more beer and in my ass crack then your butt hole.
I think that
love.
They love it.
I love,
I love it.
Yeah.
I need to start watching this show,
but then he does data.
I'm a huge fan already.
Watch it.
It's so silly.
I wish we had shows like that in English yesterday at TV.
It's really good.
They put half in English.
I'm going to start watching.
Yeah.
The facilities are very happy and uh,
and uh,
a big yeah.
Yeah.
Um hmm.
Do you want to see the biggest dad?
Boehner ever?
Yeah,
like takes it to another level of course.
Okay.
He's a hunter.
All right.
Okay.
Ah,
shit down right there.
No way
you ever seen him lose his cool down.
I quick.
Oh,
I was raised is awesome.
Such a nerd.
That guy's definitely Canadian.
That accent.
No.
Yeah.
Holy Cow.
I really liked that it was related to Garth.
Yeah.
He's such a boner.
So how about here,
here on the board and look at the,
look at the metal with the man.
This is why.
This is why we came up here.
We've been slipping along.
He's Canadian.
Huge battle.
Yeah.
Long,
tall meadow.
We're slipping along here.
Just blessing.
Just glass and glass and all of a sudden literally,
I don't even have to be blah,
isn't it on?
I'm like,
oh,
we're just blasting these.
Pick huge bedrooms.
Super
geeked.
Oh Man.
I wish I got excited about little stuff.
Anything that meat stuff.
That's how,
that's how excited I was for both of them.
I know.
That's how had super excited you were.
I was really excited.
Nothing excited.
Do you like being?
And I,
and I mean that,
I'm not just saying that for a jokey joke.
Yeah.
You've done a lot of really cool things in your career.
I would,
you have never been excited.
Like you,
you just,
you're not at an excitement dude.
But that show you are like,
what am I going to wear?
And you don't care.
You've done specials.
We were like,
I don't know.
We're just,
I don't care.
You've done late night.
We've done stuff.
Don't care.
And you were like,
I have to look good.
I have to,
you know,
prepare.
Yeah.
It's cute.
Why do you think Quentin Ito held a special place in your heart?
Um,
honestly I think it was because I've always wanted to do something Spanish,
Latin based.
It's your,
it's your roots,
its roots and you know,
I wanted like,
I want to be on Narcos,
I want to,
oh,
that'd be cool.
Yeah.
So the idea of being even in that kind of world a little bit,
I don't know,
it just,
it felt like your heritage.
Yeah.
I felt like it was like,
um,
uh,
maybe,
I don't know.
It was like hanging out with cousins or something.
Right.
I am the exact opposite.
I want nothing to do with the eastern bloc.
I want nothing to do with,
yeah,
I stuck it with a much,
they believe me.
Yeah.
Especially cause they gave me the green light.
They're like,
go for it.
They even said curse as much as you want.
That's odd then.
That's odd.
The,
yeah.
Well maybe they didn't think you'd go for it that hard.
Well,
they told me to curse in English correctly.
Like say whatever you want.
They go,
there's no rules here.
Oh,
I guess there were this guy's rad though.
He's so please thank.
He doesn't,
he doesn't have sex though,
right?
We got out here.
This is why.
What came up?
We've been slipping along.
Does it pick your battle buddies long,
tall meadow.
We've been slipping along and just glass and just all of a sudden,
literally,
I hadn't even helped me put my head on.
I'm like,
oh,
we're just glassing.
He pick huge bedrooms.
Love it.
What's glasses?
No fucking clothes.
Not Canadian,
by the way.
Of course he is.
No,
he's not master of accents.
I think you're wrong.
Uh,
that's definitely Canadian listeners.
Canadian listeners verify that man is Canadian.
Absolutely.
Whole stalk the glass and along he's talks like a total Canuck
gloss little moles Gleason.
Who's,
Huh?
Okay.
Um,
let's see.
It says there's a bunch of stuff here.
Glassing techniques plus a lock for spotting dear 10 top 10 glassing tips.
Okay.
I guess it's a stalking thing by the best binoculars you can afford.
The depth of field and clarity will be a huge difference.
July and August are the best times to glass as the deer start each glassing
session.
Cleaning your glass.
I guess it has to do with you.
Yeah.
Looking
glassing me meaning looking through the binoculars.
Yeah.
Glassing is looking at them now you realize how stoked this guy is off of
killing deer.
That's what he's stoked about is murdering a moose.
Moose.
Yeah.
Mostly.
That's what this guy is so fired up about killings.
Just like you,
you share something special with him.
Your love of killing.
I'm surprised you don't like to kill animals.
Why don't you go it?
Will Joe Rogan ever invite you?
He's asked me.
He's invited me.
I feel like you might find your true calling as a hunter and your thirst for
blood needs to develop a little,
oh,
maybe I think you'll get that violence.
Audi is the,
the anger and the rage.
That's secretly,
I don't want to listen to it.
People have sent in the clip of Bill Burr and uh,
Bert Kreischer calling you a psycho.
Yeah.
On Burke cast.
Bill burr was like,
Tom's a big cycle here.
I think bill's the biggest psycho.
No,
I think he's right.
I think you are bullshit.
New York.
Clearly a more than bill.
Bill's got a psycho pills.
Such a psycho
fill.
Such a sales,
a little cautious,
cautious about things.
But you're,
you're definitely more of a blood lust sort of guy.
I disagree.
Respectfully disagree.
I respectfully,
I'm not into hunting at all.
Why would you suggest that?
Because I think that,
and I'm not saying you can't believe you would put me ahead of him on the cycle.
I think you need to explore hunting to tap into the side of you that likes to
kill this thirst.
That side of me that likes to kill laughs at Henry Portrait of a serial killer.
The rageful beast that lurks inside needs the release.
Get outta here.
I don't like to kill animals yet.
Maybe you can get a one sided about it.
Is this guy is maybe if I were to eat them like Joe does,
he puts it to use.
If you could hunt for your family.
Oh Man,
I dunno.
I really don't.
Under the idea it does not.
It does not entice me at all.
Not the blood or the stabbing.
Maybe going back to,
I can't believe you're putting me ahead of billing on the cycle.
This,
he's so clearly a psycho.
Why is paranoid site psycho you thinking of the paranoia makes him more.
I just have a conversation.
He's so much more fired up.
He's like a,
an angry rant,
but I don't think he laughs at um,
murder.
You don't laugh.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you don't laugh at other people,
other people's harm or killing.
I like show.
If we showed bill that's that clip of Henry Portrait of a serial killer with a
hooker gets her neck twisted and broken.
And if he doesn't laugh the way you did,
I'd say that your,
your alarm isn't laugh at him killing her.
I laugh at the guy's reaction to Henry.
And what about the video of the guy's legs getting smushed by the car?
I laughed at his reaction to getting smashed by a car.
The cries of pain.
Yes,
because they were comical and a lot of people agree that it was a funny
reaction.
Okay,
but you're trying to paint me as a more of a cycle then that red headed freak
getting me.
Yes.
The best answer for glassing.
Looking at it through magnification,
either vernaculars rifle scope.
Usually when the term has said it means look looking through binoculars.
Um,
I'm not a bigger cycle.
I'm so offended by that.
Fucking ridiculous.
You're ridiculous person.
Please just keep going.
Let's glass.
Let's glass glass,
glass.
And I'm like,
holy smokes,
I got to move.
So Canadians.
And I'm like,
oh man.
I'm like,
no,
it's a cow.
The cow right there.
I've never had anybody that
so
hunting moose conversation,
he's got such Garth like blood and him.
Yeah,
dad or blood.
That's cool stuff.
Slick stuff.
Neat stuff.
Here's the a,
the super cut.
Oh,
I love it.
I have dad boner that Boehner the hunter.
We'd been slipping along here.
Just glassing.
Just glass,
glass,
glass and I'm like
just glassing.
We're just glassing.
It looks glass.
Let's glass glass on glass.
And I'm like
came in his pants.
Remember that Dad Boehner we saw today before we had lunch,
dude,
we saw a guy walking down the street wearing light denim,
like light,
light,
blue denim,
practically white denim,
tight as fuck.
High up,
Brown,
braided belt and then sandals with socks,
right?
Jeans.
Yeah.
That's like the WAC is Dab.
Look ever.
It is super whacked dude.
It is.
You want to be that like I'm really good.
That's,
that's the noise that guy made.
I think when he,
when he found out that this is question either that he spotted a mousse or that
glass went down.
Such a great,
yeah.
I liked the guy and the guy that got bitten by the snake and the cave a few
weeks back.
I remember.
Yeah,
it was a good,
a big bite.
I'll go to bed.
Bye Bye.
I've got a bad,
bad,
bad bite.
I got a bad,
bad by bad by bad bite.
I got a boob bite.
Who's just glass glasses,
glass and keeping it glass e glass in a lot.
Um,
I don't know where that is.
I remember that guy was,
I go to bed bite.
That guy.
He has a bad bike.
I,
I don't remember all the Guano Guano blood everywhere.
I'm cool.
No,
I'm knee deep in Guano and back one.
Oh,
these hunting guys,
these outdoorsy types on a nightmare.
Oh,
neat.
Even back one.
Okay.
What happens to,
to men when they turn in the boners,
like do you think he's always been a boner and then becoming a dad just makes
you lamer or is it,
is it becoming a dad that just makes you a lay person?
Maybe it's just when you stop chasing pus,
I think so
your energy needs to go somewhere else.
Yeah.
And some dudes like,
you know,
like maybe it coincides with testosterone dropping.
So it's like that's what it is.
Should be like,
what am I going to put my,
my dream,
you know,
my tribe
being a boner at a time.
See that goes away.
Right.
And then you go,
I need something else to do.
Right.
You know
it's glass and you get all stoked about stuff like that.
Stan Umma building.
I'll do other things.
It's like how women shut it down after they have kids too.
They,
they stopped being a lady and the um,
get their hair cut real bad.
Yup.
And they shut down the vagina to shut it down,
man.
You got to shut it down because you stopped.
You stopped being sexual.
It's the same thing with women.
Yeah.
You gotta fight.
You gotta fight the fight man to stay as sexual being after you have kids.
Where is,
what was that what,
what episode was when?
I don't remember.
I don't remember because that was excellent,
man.
That was so good.
Is it in here?
Um,
maybe it's so funny man.
Uh,
here's,
I'm a bike.
I remember that.
I'm a bike or that lady.
No,
you don't remember that.
She sat on the front of a bus,
a city us and she goes,
I'm a bike.
Yeah.
And she made them try to get them to take her because I,
this is for bikes and she goes,
I am a bike,
um,
yelling at the thing.
I don't know where it is.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
We can move on.
I don't want to.
Okay.
You rather have dead air.
It's not better.
They're not dead air.
Okay,
well I'll fill the air while you look for something.
I,
um,
I was very upset on this tour that I went on the main mother goddess tour
because all the toilets that I took shits in.
We're regular toilets and I felt what it was like to have life before the total
washlet.
Yeah.
And we've had the washlet in our lives since March,
since we moved into this rental home.
And it really has changed me into a civilized human being.
I no longer shit to shower because I no longer have to with a toto washlet.
Uh,
but I found myself going back to my old ways on the road.
Tom.
How so?
Well,
I would take a dump in the hotel and I would wipe and wipe and wipe and the
wives just kept on coming.
So I had to go straight to shower and now,
now,
well now I'm back home.
But it was really gross.
It just felt gross,
like mashing all that shit into my butthole all the time.
That's what normal people do that don't have wash let's,
yeah.
So disgusting.
And with you and your hair,
that must be even gross or when you're on the road.
I have a,
I got it.
As soon as I got to New York this week I had a big old nasty travel day dump and
it was nice because the hotel bathroom was so tight to the sink.
So at least you could go,
I'm sorry to the sink.
Yeah.
So like you sat next to a sink,
you could soak toilet paper,
you know what I mean?
Hmm.
That's even Nastier to me.
I'd rather just get in the shower.
How has that now grosser than just getting up and going to shower.
So you'd wet you'd whether toilet paper and then smush it and smush it and Smush
it that way.
Yeah.
How many times did you have to do that?
Mm,
I dunno.
I remember probably five or six.
See to me that's more work.
Like maybe just go and take a shower,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm on this new diet.
Um,
cause I'm,
I started seeing a fitness trainer.
Yeah.
And I'm on what's called a primal diet and I eat a lot of oils and fats,
good fats.
And the thing is in the morning,
I'm sure I drink coffee with coconut oil and organic butter in it.
It's like a shake and it's supposed to keep you full longer and it does,
but it also makes you have to shit shit bad dude.
Oh my God.
I drank my coffee this morning.
I was getting Ellis up,
changing him and as I was changing his diaper,
I had the need to fill mine.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I did like fucking run downstairs.
I threw him in there like just play their hand.
Just took a really fear shit today.
Okay.
How bad was it?
It was intense.
It was like so much to like so much poop comes out of you and you,
you realize how much there is inside of you.
That's,
I live for those shifts where you're just surprised.
I know.
Me Too.
[inaudible] when you amaze yourself,
that's when I feel like those types of shifts are the ones that,
that um,
that make you go,
I'm never going to not try to shut this big,
you know?
Right.
They inspire you to do bigger,
better dumps.
Yeah,
exactly.
Did you find the clip?
He sees good in me.
Then I got a bad bite.
I got a bad bite.
I got a bad,
but I got a bad back.
I got a bad bite,
man.
I've got a bad bite to the leg.
I've got a bad bite and I got really bad body stuff.
I've got a really bad bite,
man.
My legs are killing me.
I've got a really good,
I gotta get home.
I got a really bad by,
oh,
I got a bad bite.
I love how much you,
that's about it.
When you got bad.
Yeah.
He doesn't do anything.
He just talks about it.
It's bad.
Waist,
deep bat Guano kept saying it.
Got a big open wound and all this.
All this last one.
Oh,
oh,
I'm dying.
There's the tail is planning something.
Yes.
Something's going on like that.
He's planning something and squeezing you very tightly.
It's terrifying.
Dude.
Leave.
Damn.
That was terrible.
Yeah.
All right.
I couldn't leave it alone.
Sorry.
Hmm.
Maybe happy.
I'm a psycho member.
Yeah.
Can't believe you that you say that so offensive to me.
Seriously.
How could you think that?
How can you think of that?
Cause I live with you.
I know you.
I've known you for years.
So full of Shit.
What does that mean?
I think bill's point was that it's secretly lurking.
Like one thing could set you off.
I see that happening like over the years.
Um,
maybe like the thing will set you off and then who knows?
That's why I think hunting might be good for you.
It's like a release valve for all that rage,
secret rage inside of you.
They would rather,
you know,
heard a person than an animal though.
That's what I'm saying Mary Go.
But maybe we can channel that person hating into the animals.
You know when they make it like a healthier aggression thing.
I really liked that you,
you did speak in a dad.
Boners and Garth.
We uh,
we have an older,
I would have,
FIFA is tweaked
twitched
older.
Garth interview.
Oh,
I love Garth.
Like the origins of Dad boner.
Okay.
If me,
I got to pull every trick.
I know a lot of the hat because I want these people to crawl out of this place.
I want her to be exhausted and I want them to feel what I'm feeling.
I haven't found a better word for it,
so please excuse me for what I'm about to say.
Sex
now you go,
okay.
Listen to how he describes it.
He's a real,
so is just a thousand miles an hour.
It's the wildest thing.
And then in the flip of a heart,
it goes to this nice Tinder soft thing and he find everybody leaning in and all
of a sudden it's just
Garth sex for you,
blah,
blah.
Just like he knows how to put out though,
right?
I don't know.
I Dunno.
I think Garth really,
really consumes you and you're his sexual partner.
He's annoying.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the guy that's going to light the hundred candles and the bath.
He's going to make intense eye contact.
Lots of,
lots of eye contact.
Shows you the tone a lot before.
I do like that throw up.
I wish there was some way,
some way you could step inside.
Nothing.
See what it is.
You see.
Oh my God.
There are times actually when I swear to God to you that you could just fly.
It's so cool.
It's all the things that you've always wanted to cut loose and let loose and
just fly that you never thought you could do,
but it actually happens.
Oh Man.
So He's been this boner for a long time.
This is a old interview.
This has gotta be 20 years old.
He really believes his own bullshit.
He drinks his own Koolaid.
Oh yeah.
It's like,
it's like fine.
Can I tell you I don't buy it.
I don't buy it.
I just think that he's,
I think,
I think he's a little contrived and uh,
I,
I feel like he's a bit of a sociopath.
I don't buy it.
It's so cool.
So cool.
I don't buy it.
He's a weird something.
Something's going on there.
I do.
I think something's dealing.
I mean,
look,
the guy's talented.
I'm not saying that he's not a talented person,
but I don't believe this nonsense
sex.
It's a elder.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
I can see why you,
I can just say
it is wonderful.
It's very addictive too.
Okay.
Would you rather,
would you have sex with Garth Brooks or the Vegan Vagina guy?
Oh,
100% Garth Brooks.
I am close.
Why?
Dude is bearable.
[inaudible] Vagina Guy.
Oh my.
And he's disgusting.
Disgusting.
John Suck.
Or this guy's full of himself.
He's a megalomaniac superstar.
Yeah.
But that dude is gross.
He's gross and full of himself,
you know,
and he's missing teeth.
Oh,
Garth has at least you're going to have a nice situation to do it in a nice
situation.
Yeah.
He has a nice house and know we forgot what our perfect smiles.
I know they're in the next room.
You vamped for a minute.
I'll go grab them.
While we wore those perfect smiles on Instagram and people really enjoyed them.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Bad,
right?
I Dunno.
I have no idea where they are.
I have no idea.
None where the perfect smiles are.
Please don't ask me.
But um,
you know,
that's an unpaid sponsorship.
Nobody asked us to promote the perfect smile.
Nobody paid us to promote the perfect smile.
We just got perfect smiles on our own and we wore them and we showed them to
everybody on Instagram and I don't think it could be any better,
man.
I felt so much more confident.
I feel like I'm going to get that date.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go get that interview.
I'm going to get that job now that my teeth are perfect.
So we have perfect smiles now.
Oh,
nice.
Dead Air.
You only thing about dead air.
That's the ultimate death move.
What you put these in and just look at the camera just for you to know.
I know,
but I'm saying we're both to talk.
That was point.
I told you the damn.
All right.
I did talk.
I'm talking about are you gave me the perfect smile and I'll put it in and I
just told them how much more confident I felt she was getting it.
Total smile.
Confidence.
These are the worst things.
I've seen better teeth at the Halloween store.
They kind of looked like Halloween teeth.
They look white,
worser than him.
Then I kind of showed you how to,
how to put them in for pictures,
so the problem is is I was actually trying to put them in like they were of
veneers,
but you put them in your lips and then they'll actually,
you actually look like you have old,
old eastern bloc teeth when you wear them like that.
Yeah.
Right now they just look like,
oh wow.
She had her,
she had her teeth fixed and the early seventies in the Ukraine or something.
Right.
That's what it looks like in Hungary.
Mine look like dog teeth.
I'm clear.
It sounds it.
Smile and venture commercials.
The perfect map.
Now here's crazy part with the perfect
and you is that these are shaped almost exactly like your real teeth.
The gums are too bloody and red,
but the shape of them is identical to what you got
date with somebody though.
And they had these in be able to tell.
You'd be like,
what is up with her teeth?
Her no horse right away.
Okay.
Cause they wouldn't be in their lips.
They would be in their mouth.
You know what I mean?
People wear them.
Who have,
um,
the problem with this also is it sits on your other teeth.
So somebody who has,
let's say two bad teeth here,
right?
You put this in,
it's still sitting over your other,
yeah,
it's too chunky.
Yeah.
The,
the design flaw.
There's a few design flaws.
Number one,
these are for women.
So men and women have different shapes.
Teeth and these are too small for most men.
And the gums were bloody.
And that's too thick and chunky.
Yeah.
If you were to melt,
first of all,
I would not trust this shit.
Sticking it to your teeth.
Oh fuck.
Now to melt this plastic and they don't melt it to you.
You're supposed to put it in hot water and it loosens the glue and then you pop
on and then they adhere to your real team,
which helps even more confident now.
It should.
Perfect smile cabinet todo smell.
Confidence tonal.
Ma'Am.
Um,
you know that this Guy John wrote to us?
Yes.
I met him.
Reviewed his denim.
Oh,
you did?
I did.
I met him in person.
Came to one of the shows in a Texas,
I believe.
Hmm.
Um,
did,
did his denim come up there?
Yeah,
he goes,
I'm the one that sent you the picture.
We've had multiple pictures sent in though though.
There's this guy in particular.
Yeah.
And then he,
uh,
he got 'em.
He got 'em my tailor better.
Yeah,
much better.
That's all we're talking about.
Good job.
Much better.
Yeah.
It just looks better.
It looks so much better.
Good job.
You know how to wear your jeans now.
Total gene confidence.
Yeah.
Total genes.
Confidence.
A Nice job,
sir.
John,
is it good job.
We allow you to wear your genius for you.
Good for you.
Hey,
did you wonder about making dog food since you ate some a while ago?
I'm Lisa had to see,
I'm the founder of your pet shop and he may,
looks like ally's dog food and treats here in Chicago.
We use all human grade ingredients.
Oh,
that we puree up into bars.
This looks really cool.
Cards.
Yeah,
into burrs.
You read that
whole foods or a more natural diet.
Wild Diet.
It really helps them have a longer,
better quality of life.
Wow.
Y'All,
before dogs were domesticated,
they ate what they killed and they ate withdraw.
So we prepared food raw.
We do like baking or freeze dried.
So we really take a lot of those history lessons and include them.
I kind of want to get some of her dog treats.
Hi.
Yeah.
I kinda feel like there's something I need to ask for so that I can eat these
treats.
You know what I mean?
I wasn't thinking like that.
Like we should buy them.
No,
I'm thinking that I've been eyeballing this necklace that I wanted to get and I
to eat some of these traits.
If you'd buy me that necklace,
by the way,
when I was on the road,
you want this food.
When I of course when I was in a,
I think it was Cincy this girl goes,
hey,
is that the ring you got for eating dog food?
And I go,
yeah,
actually
she noticed from the stage the stage.
So there's a necklace I want that matches this ring.
I would totally eat this dog food if you'd get me the necklace.
But it seems like you really are enjoying dog food.
Bring that up as well.
I don't then it doesn't have to be dog food is or something else you want me to
do.
Uh,
Louis loosely,
godless treats for breathing.
I just kept feeding her and feeding her.
So we put her on the Lucy Diet.
She got,
you know,
a little more Pumpkin,
a little more green means a little more whole foods.
And she was able to lose 22 pounds,
six months.
And that was a pivotal point for me in creating your pet shop.
Aw,
I looks delicious.
Sounds pretty cool.
No maggots though.
I'd like my maggots.
How about this?
This came up.
So they have this menu for my dog,
right?
Chip,
lefties,
food.
Can you imagine
Serina Williams,
the greatest female tennis player of all time?
Yeah,
chip is three years old and he's been traveling for three years.
The little guy leaves his food at home.
He doesn't pack food.
So this hotel in the Dusky menu
chips not supposed to pack his own food.
You are.
That's very true.
But look at that menu.
That's a doggy man.
Yeah,
I've seen that before.
Third and yeah,
certain hotels.
I was like,
that looks so good.
It was like fresh,
like Greens and boil chicken and beef.
And it was seared.
It was seared like tenderly and it was just perfection.
And I was like,
fat looks like the best food looks better than my food.
Right?
So
I might want to taste it.
Suits.
So I ordered him the salmon and rice because I thought I ate salmon.
So I ordered a seven rice before you judge me and look at it.
Look,
that's the Santa and right,
let's kind of all mixed together,
right?
Yeah.
I'm like,
what the heck?
I'm going to try a piece.
It looks good.
So I eat a spoonful.
Don't judge me.
I ate a spoonful.
Let's fast forward to two hours.
I just went into the toilet like,
like I thought I was gonna pass out.
Really?
I mean it,
it did taste weird.
Like I've forced,
I forced swallowed it like
whoa.
That was like,
well you did.
Yeah,
but I,
I don't know if this sounds like it affected her dumps.
I did.
You didn't say it smelled like dog food.
Remember?
It didn't smell like dog should,
I mean,
yeah.
That's interesting.
So,
but we learned about the w the reason why it's their anal glands that make the
dog smell like dogs.
She would have been like,
Yo,
it didn't smell like dog stuff.
Like my shot,
like it tastes a little bit like a house cleaner kind of thing.
I don't know what his name is,
dog food.
But chip liked it.
And it looked good,
but I don't think it's consumable.
Consumable for you minutes.
Um,
they should have
the only thing that would have this better would it be at the end of,
she was like,
Thompson,
girl,
you gotta buy me some jewelry.
I bought this ring.
I ate that.
Then today I paid 15 year olds for that stuff that's making me go to the
bathroom.
I mean,
doing number two is I need a life.
She was right.
You need to get you,
I really do need to get
life.
Oh my God.
She is listening to our show.
You know the dog food,
they get y'all out.
I didn't get sick when I ate,
um,
fiefs food.
Uh,
but they must have given them,
I mean,
dog stomachs are way stronger than ours.
She said it tasted like cleaning agent.
Maybe it was like just like out of the dumpster,
you know,
and she had one bite and it made her shit.
Like that's crazy.
Then again,
her system might be so strictly queen because she's a pro athlete that just like
me,
Bam.
Just like me.
You like any,
any little variation maybe makes Brown happen,
I guess.
Yeah,
that's really weird though.
That's a,
that's a lot of fancy shift for dogs to Nice,
nice joint.
Do or she staying?
Well you mean those are the prices for dogs.
I can imagine what the people as well for a plate of shitty dog,
it's like close to 30 bucks.
That's glory.
It almost two to one.
What is the euro dollar?
Like a dollar and a half.
It was last time we went there,
but I'm sure it's worse.
Way Worse for now.
Breck
it's closer now to what?
One to one.
So 15 bucks is $16 oh wow.
Much closer.
So weaker euro.
Debbie,
since Brexit,
Ace Brits.
If you're not from hair,
get out.
Africans do a job's and the polar works.
There's so many.
Polacks last time we went,
the whole labor force was Polish people and when I lived there in the late
nineties it wasn't like that for sure.
It looks like 2014
mid 2014 was the height of the value really?
What was it?
Uh,
it just shows it's just a chart.
It was up to 1.4 times.
What are you eating?
Stupid.
Just over 1.4,
okay.
Almost one and a half times.
And then 2015 saw the biggest dip to almost equal or which is basically where
it's at now.
It's almost equal.
It's time to go to England,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
well no,
because they're out of the euro market now.
Uh,
the outro,
let's see,
let's see what dollar depends on
dude,
British pound.
Oh,
the pound is weaker than the dollar.
You're right.
So
the British pay on it.
When we went,
it was definitely stronger.
It was kicking our ass.
And when I was there in the nineties it was kicking our ass too.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Nope.
Brexit is doing thanks.
Wow.
Interesting.
Oof.
That's rough.
Rough seas over there right now.
No.
Yeah,
it is a good time for a trip there.
I know
my,
we have this kid leave them or just fly for like 10 hours.
Kids love being on planes.
Small babies.
They love it.
Yeah.
So horrible.
We could do that.
You want to take him?
I would do it and then fuck up his sleeve schedule.
Oh my God.
Could you imagine?
I would do it.
Um,
next summer,
like he's old.
He's older.
Yeah.
I think year and a half you could still get him to sit in your lap.
I think he needs his own.
Even at this stage,
his own dude,
he's all over the place.
I took him to the eye doctor today.
Like he'll sit on your lap for like 10 minutes and then he's like,
well,
he just wants to crawl around and investigate.
Yeah.
He doesn't want any kind of lab business for that long.
No lap business too adventurous dude.
Yeah.
No,
he ain't doing it.
Yeah.
But at this age it would suck to travel with them.
Even though I met that guy who's like,
oh yeah,
we went to Paris with our five month old.
I was like,
what?
Yeah.
You went to Paris with him.
You know,
I guess those people have a much stronger constitution than you and I,
because I,
yeah.
The,
the thought of it is a,
it sounds like a nightmare to me.
I think those people just were not built for that.
We're not,
we're not.
I think you can just be like,
yeah,
it's going to suck and I'm going to do it anyway.
People that need like a perfect smile,
but not to be like,
you know,
stressed out on a plane.
You cannot eat with that on your date.
There's no way you can,
I didn't eat,
I went on a date with this by the way.
The date went great.
I think she really liked me and I just didn't eat,
you know,
and she was like,
aren't you going to order something?
And I was like,
all right.
I had a late lunch.
I had a light lunch.
Phil,
I've,
I don't have much of an appetite.
I got the job with my perfect smile and she goes,
what about she goes,
can I get a kiss goodnight and go,
I'm not wanting to rush to do that for a movie on a second date and I'll take it
out.
I carried her casket night.
I got the job with my perfect.
You got to,
you got the job.
How was the interview
please?
That's good.
Not that aware of the rubric.
Yeah,
you look like somebody I would hire.
As soon as I saw that,
I was like,
Scott,
a nice smile I think are going to hire for this.
Perfect.
That girl's got a perfect smile.
Who Do you want it to work?
Who Do you want representing your company?
This guy,
wait,
is that the whites of your eyes match the whiteness of those teeth,
but it makes you look dead.
Kind of like the dentist.
What's his name that runs the the the bunny ranch.
Dennis Hoff.
That's what happens when your teeth are like fake,
fake,
fake looking white and then they match the whites of your eyes.
It makes you look like the crypt keeper.
You look dead.
He looks,
he looks terrible.
And then you posted,
did you post a picture of the that team owner that you liked with the haircut
look like that
areas that dirty pants.
It's such a scum.
Fuck.
Those teeth are too white now and it looks terrible.
He looks dead till.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I'm like good old ass pimp.
Yeah,
he's a gross.
So gross.
Look how he's holding that chick's snack.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Creeper.
He was creepy on that show and he was,
yeah,
I got my perfect smile.
We were so excited when this showed up.
The perfect smile.
It's the only 1599 and then 1599 for shipping and handling such scumbags.
Yeah.
Cause if you're broken enough that you need the perfect smile,
you can't afford $15 in shipping.
I think this is back when he had his teeth.
See if it looks better.
It's so much better.
So much better.
Cause then that matches the oldness of state.
Yeah,
I'll look jaggedy it's fine.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're talking about Davis.
Mark Davis.
Yeah.
That guy looks good too.
Let's see if he's smiling.
Oof.
So crazy.
Yeah.
Oh well.
Oh here he is.
Kind of,
but like I said,
remember how it said he drives 500 miles to get this haircut.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
Those teeth aren't good.
Those are weird teeth and he's now a lot of money.
He should afford better tea.
Oh my God.
500 million.
He's got $500 million.
Just spend a few of those dollars on teeth,
bro.
And a haircut.
Cool hair,
Yannick cool haircut.
Somebody said,
I think I said it back then,
that if,
uh,
he's the Kinda guy that if people stop talking about his haircut,
he would change it.
Oh right.
People are like,
that guys cut your hair.
He's like,
nope.
Like that's his thing.
Yeah.
Has Personality thing is,
yeah.
You telling me to do it.
I'm not gonna do it.
Well,
that didn't think you're maybe hurting yourself on that one though.
Yeah.
That and it makes you more interesting.
That's your,
your hook.
It's like the guy that has the exotic pet.
Who's that guy looks like he's retarded because of the haircut.
He's an interesting guy.
His name is mark.
Right.
We'll talk to them.
It's like the guy that walks down Venice beach with a snake around his nae.
Yeah.
Any,
any does it cause people go pair it?
Yeah.
Well it's just my thing.
I got a lizard on a,
yeah,
I keep it around my neck.
You can pet it.
It's cool.
Yeah.
I'm gonna feed them fucking rats everyday.
South beach too.
There's a lot of that.
I got an Iguana,
petty Guana around my neck.
Seems unusual.
Whoa.
I'm kind of an unusual guy.
I'm kind of weird like that.
Okay.
Just a little misdirected energy.
Little bit,
a little,
little bit.
Um,
let's see somebody,
there's some emails here,
which,
why am h song should these mommy's train their kid to someone said,
I'm about to become a mommy myself.
Our Carl's Jr is due March 2nd that's not right around the corner.
Um,
my friend recently recommended to me to begin a song to sing a song every day to
baby jeans and then when baby jeans is born it will recognize the song,
go to sleep.
She said it worked for her.
So why not give it a try?
My husband and I have been trying to figure out which your mom's house song
would best suit this instance.
We were hoping to have some insight from the main mommies.
Husband is leaning towards red,
red wine.
I tend to lean towards Miami fart machine to worry.
It might be too energetic for Carl's junior.
Go to sleep to thoughts,
suggestions.
Thank you Katie and Ryan.
Like a lullaby.
Yeah.
Well something that,
you know,
they hear it and they're like,
ah.
Right.
I mean Conga,
the,
the FARC,
Congo,
but she's right.
That's pretty high energy.
You're going to sleep.
Come on.
I agree.
I liked Theo's jam.
Yeah.
It's 10,
10,
10 times 10 with s on the Anna from the hunted by Jan [inaudible].
That's a good one.
Or um,
ah,
my fucking cat.
My cat.
My cat might be a lot for a little.
You don't think it's a lot for a child?
No.
Seems really aggressive for a,
for a,
I think.
Yeah.
Okay.
I love you mom.
Hi Bobby.
Hi Mom.
What about that?
Uh,
that fart song.
Oh my gosh,
that's a good,
nice,
oh
hell to the Nah,
it's good.
That's kind of,
that's kind of it.
I think you got it.
Yeah.
Good.
Which has clearly modified sample of,
um,
with Marvin Gaye Song.
Hi.
All right.
I'm talking about they all sound like that.
Yeah.
Marvin Gaye Song.
Yeah,
but that's definitely,
um,
whatever.
I can't think of the name of this.
I know what I'm talking about it or no,
I do,
but I don't know the titles to any Marvin Gaye Song.
Really?
Okay.
Anyways,
it's making me crazy.
Um,
yeah.
I think my clients a really,
I think hell to the NAS.
Great.
Cause it's a positive message for a child to establish healthy boundaries.
When I get the right one.
Yeah.
Oh that's right.
It's a,
it's a good song to teach somebody boundaries.
Hell No.
He teach that baby.
You know,
you want to go with strangers,
no
name visual wagon from the first church and nothing but the truth.
Alright baby.
There you go.
Yeah.
Your bath,
you got a choice.
You read your book a bottle,
drink your bottle and then thank God for the blood warming my veins.
Not Insane.
Come to please do.
Hey
kills good
doula.
No,
no,
no.
Come on.
No,
no,
no.
This is great.
So
that's a good song.
I'm on board.
I think it's a great song.
I think it really is.
I'm trying to think if there's any,
have an old guys show you where his bathing suit covers.
Hell No.
You teach the kid?
How did the no,
no,
no.
Right.
Um,
you want to do drugs?
Hell no turning.
No,
no,
no.
It might be a bit much right
now.
Maybe not dead dragon for the baby.
Yeah.
Mm hmm.
No.
What the fuck is this?
Oh yeah.
Good one.
Good cautionary tale.
I don't know if it's a bit much for going to sleep.
A little subdued.
No,
I think hell yeah.
Hmm.
Um,
well,
here's what you use at first suggested
patriotic
in other words.
Yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it's sexy.
We've had made it known that's still in the top.
That's,
I think that's Max Newman.
Is that right?
I think so.
Um,
but I'll be wine cannoli.
He's got the hits the ghost.
Cruz got the,
his Max to Max has done a fax,
has got the heads.
I mean,
these are all heavy hitters.
Why Mh Crow?
[inaudible]
yeah,
I think that's a good wake up in the morning to fun song.
Yeah.
That's how you start your day.
So hell to the nozzle Lullaby at night.
And then city connection is the good morning.
Yeah.
Unless you wanted it to be.
Oh,
this is,
this is another timeless classic.
Absolutely love this one.
Just musically
they still haven't dropped at the farts.
Are the instrument incredible about this?
[inaudible]
do you want to hear a Peter Stain?
I feel like this could be a club.
Is it?
I had full on press pause button and I have a good thought.
Yeah.
Is it?
If I had like a radio station hookup,
I would give them,
oh my gosh.
And be like,
just start planning.
This is a new lady Gaga Song and not tell anybody.
It's like a y age song and I think that song is good enough and clubby enough
that people would be like,
yeah,
this isn't fucking jam
through it.
Knowing who knows what it is.
Okay.
I love Peter Stain too.
Yeah.
This is hilarious.
[inaudible]
we played the horns in a one.
Also make some art.
Take his pussy.
I can say whatever I fucking want.
It's gross.
I don't want to wear diapers.
My Brown say hello.
I'm Sam.
My fucking head control of my own garage and a woman's arm refer to me as
Excentra.
Man.
What a Dick.
What the fuck is the matter with you,
dude?
Like I give a fucking shit.
I love being a racist redneck.
Intellectuals.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I don't really care what your opinion as Christina said.
Brilliant stuff,
man.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
Sorry.
Okay.
Smoking crack
and
so good.
It's so good.
You think I give a fucking shit.
That's Peter Stain.
That will be one man.
He made that one the game.
Yeah,
the cannoli did,
did great.
And these songs,
man,
there's so good.
Yeah.
Really talented people
were bored.
My Endo airport in the Orlando Airport near Orlando Airport.
Now the best,
uh,
top dog ones is the trance,
I think.
Yes.
Matthew Miller.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Yeah,
he's
out of money.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Absolutely know.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
Um,
these dogs got to eat their dinner.
I know.
It's a little standing there.
Like how learn,
I'm going to let them out real quick or you are okay.
Go ahead.
Let them out that time out.
Yeah.
Do,
do Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Let's see.
Hi,
Mommy's.
Yup.
Yup,
What?
All right.
Do you like how she just,
Oh,
by the way,
you know what I'm an Irish lady said to me,
MMM
Irish lady.
He said to me after a short one of the shows in New York,
what's that?
She goes,
I don't mean to be two ends of a cunt,
but do you mind if I take a picture?
Oh,
that's good.
Two ends of a,
I've never heard that.
And Pena would love that.
Yeah.
That's a special one.
Two ends of a cut.
That's funny.
Couldn't believe it.
Um,
much mummies.
Whoa.
Ah,
a la
Sun's going down.
That means the trick or treaters are going to start coming.
So Shit.
Yeah,
we gotta get our candies.
Readies we're um,
yeah,
I got good candy by the way.
I didn't get fucking bullshit.
I got Reesy cups and snickers.
Those are too high value treats.
That's true.
Nothing worse than Shitty Candy.
Right?
Did she,
the urine homeless men
have sex with your sister.
They give a face.
Grandmother walks in on you masturbating.
Never have another
trying to play this time of day.
Would you rather happen
jeans?
Would you rather lose your voice and only be able to speak through soundboard
drops from the podcast for a month?
Yup.
Or have to talk like top dog for a year.
Uh,
what's wrong?
What's hotdogs talking?
What's the dilemma?
I guess if you want to have kind of like top dog for a year buddy.
Right.
Just sound rops but that's for a month.
Every communicate everything with us now it's like,
oh my fucking cat.
Oof.
Um,
I guess I do top dog just cause you can still talk like a person.
I mean people would be like,
why are you talking like a older white guy?
But yeah,
I'm almost there so I feel like it's real easy for me to really close.
Yeah.
At the top dog people keep telling me too,
they're like,
oh,
you sound a lot like your dad.
Yeah.
Shutting more like,
um,
so yeah,
becoming a dad makes you your dad.
Yeah.
I know.
It's kind of depressing though,
right?
A little bit.
Yeah.
Once you start to process it,
you're like,
oh shit dude.
Totally.
You're your zoning like him a little bit to check,
check out.
What's that?
What's that buddy?
Yeah.
Oh,
I,
yeah.
I wasn't nothing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
That one's an easy one.
What are you pick?
No,
definitely just talk like we're already like for a year,
a month of fucking answering questions from a sound like you imagine trying to
express yourself all day.
Like that horrible man search for the dry eye level while at there,
you know?
Right.
That's right.
You're just talking like that.
Oh my God.
That's hard to talk like that
today.
Big words.
That's a lot.
It's hard,
man.
How do you communicate?
You couldn't ask for anything.
No.
You'd have to build words.
You'd have to build new sentences with the words that you had.
It would take forever.
Would you rather have to start every conversation talking retarded or start
every conversation talking in a baby talk.
Ah,
that's tough.
Where you're like,
yeah,
get book.
Like he would talk to Betsy or Fifo
or talking retarded.
I don't know what that means.
Does that mean the toggling retired like Stevie's girlfriend?
Well,
the thing is,
I think people would really look at you so much crazier if you just started
talking retarded as opposed to baby,
they'd be like,
this is eccentric.
You talk retarded.
If you were like,
oh,
we want to write that,
people would be like,
Whoa,
whoa dude.
People just walk away from you and well,
what I would do is that they think you're mocking that more marketing.
Yeah.
I would carry a dog with me at all times.
You have to.
You could have one of them.
One free 10.
Yeah,
and then I could just be like,
hey,
got blue again.
I don't think I'm just talking to the dog.
Yeah.
Cause talking retarded.
That's a hard segue.
Yeah,
it is.
Sure is.
I mean you slept and incorporated that into your act,
which I feel like would increase the value retarded.
The biggest retarded give you want to move tickets.
Yeah.
Talk to your agent.
Just see what he thinks.
Let's see what Andrew thinks about this idea.
I like the idea,
Andrew thinking about doing a whole retarded act.
The,
see,
I can't see him not thinking it would go well.
It was,
I would take the baby talk by the way.
Hey Buddy.
Oh,
hi babies.
Hi Schnitzel.
I pencils.
So it's hard walking.
Hi everybody.
Hi.
So they would just think,
oh,
he's just like a sweet,
like a nice,
dopey give you go hi am when Bonnie,
how?
That's kind of fun here.
See,
I feel like I,
I liked it.
It was funnier when you did it.
It was hard to look at you.
Like,
why are you doing that?
You know,
it says start every conversation.
It's a very specific,
would you rather wait?
Which is good.
It's good to be specific.
We have for dinner and then they go,
um,
I'll have chicken and then you go chicken too.
Wait,
what was that?
See,
I think from a comedic perspective,
I would choose retarded,
but from a life perspective,
the baby talk.
Okay.
Um,
what'd you,
Ooh,
it's already starts off.
It starts off cut.
Would you rather have to wear a wet socks all day?
I hate it.
But you can't take off for bedtime.
God dammit.
Who've had his terrible or would you rather have all your meals by chewed be
chewed by each other and fed like a baby bird for a week or wet socks or you're
fed food?
Like I chew it.
I got it.
I understand what baby birding is.
Do you know that?
Um,
something like that would chew it up,
threw it up and then I would chew it up and then I would,
then I would chew it up and then I would put it in your mouth,
chewing it up.
The girl that did Clarissa explains it,
all of that show.
I think she was pre chewing.
No,
no,
it was the hot girl from the 90s in that Arrow Smith,
the clueless girl Alicia Silverstone show or something.
She was baby birding,
her child,
uh,
pre mastication where she would chew the food and then put it in our kid's mouth
and she was an advocate of that.
This gusting,
I think it's so gross though,
so gross that I would actually take the wet socks because I mean,
I would vomit.
If you're chewing your food
and you're supposed to do it for a week.
I mean,
I just,
you know what,
the wet socks is horrible,
but it's like anything you kind of adapt after.
You just wouldn't,
you get and you,
you wouldn't sleep the first night and you'd be so tired by the second night
that you,
your body would just shut down.
He used to it.
Worst put on fresh ones leave and you step up.
Step in a spot yet god damn it.
And you have to change.
Yeah.
No,
it's misery that is miseries.
One of the small,
humongous inconveniences.
I mean,
I know people are talking about this whole Syrian situation,
but I feel like wet socks has even more than Vegas from.
Yeah.
Your Dad talks about that in Vietnam.
Um,
when he would have wet socks in your boots.
That's right.
Trench foot or something.
Right.
You dry your socks out.
Yeah.
Her feet would get all fung.
See that's like the,
that's one of the biggest problems they had to add feed.
Debbie.
My Dad's got them feet.
Yeah,
definitely.
It looks like you've spent years.
And now I'm with those all yellow Nascar.
We gotta run.
Jamie got me so nasty time.
So nasty.
Thank you guys for listening to the show.
Please visit the new store.
Um,
you can get through to it.
You can go to Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com.
Click on the store,
your mom's house,
podcast.com and click on the store.
We're now part of merchant method.
Uh,
we have the new Dj dad mouth shirt up and we restocked a bunch of shirts.
Bikes has been restocked.
Um,
yeah,
that was just a,
okay,
cool.
Oh,
that was a couple other,
yeah,
it's fine.
A couple of other ones.
Uh,
we restock,
I think it was a high and tight,
maybe a FIFO one.
So those are ready to go.
Please check out the store and thank you to all the Patriot and subscribers.
patrion.com/mom a few bucks gets you an extra episode of your mom's house every
month.
So thank you everybody for listening to that.
We gotta go,
we gotta go celebrate holiday jeans.
Low Jeans is here.
This is a DJ stand in mom.
Uh,
also known as guy with a bite.
The end of Your Dad's Dick off.
Um,
here we go.
I love it.
Thank you guys for listening.
Here it goes
stairs.
Well,
and
your Dad,
your dad,
right?
The
merits,
the blood,
blood.
Don't
fight,
fight.
And your dad done here?
Mirror the blood blood.
Nope.